un très très bien hardy choc mais si
belloc celui qui préfère la blanche
boutons blancs ni de l'aude b pour kepa
édition lieux communs pas banal alors
denis belloc en 87 jeux publiés mais on
est tout de suite
marguerite duras a fait des tas d'éloges
sur son bouquin elle a dit que c'était
une exacte exactitude si vous êtes
devenus copains ça s'est passé comment
entre vous ça s'est passé
très vite de la bombe en premier lieu
elle a eu le manuscrit sont enfin le
bouquin son bureau duras n'aime pas
notre allée des bouquins des manuscrits
pebble à force d'insistance l'homme a eu
ras-le-bol d'avoir ce cas là dessus et
ils achètent pour être vrai ça raconte
et quan et en sarre à contes émouvant
mon enfance son adolescence à l'enfance
avec le faire un résultat on a connu ce
qu'ils ne meurent jamais un an et demi
le nom à leur mariage de la mère avec un
espagnol métal et la prochaine épreuve
et la prison d'abord le nom correction
plus gagné à présent pour des cas ce vol
qualifié
ça fait longtemps présents bon j'ai fait
trois fois de la prison j'ai fait mouche
pas fait très longtemps j'ai quatre mois
en belgique je vais quatre mois à
freiner quelques mois on joue craque ça
raconte l homosexualité et où la
découverte homosexualité très tôt très
précoce à pigalle sur le boulevard pie
ix à la prostitution et le temps
j'entends de puiseaux
voilà où c'est bien l'argent je c'est
pas vrai n'est au chargement je pense ma
constitution censée rendre une question
de l'argent je crois pas en mangeant
cipal persuadé je pense qu'on fait ça
comme ça parce qu'il ya rien à l'horizon
que le pognon j'ai passé six ans après
tête et suzanne en 87 dans la ville va
finir le maire est idéal pour les tarifs
et les ferries et une histoires venues
parce que mélo mais qui n'a rien
d'extraordinaire rien d'original c'est
une sorte qu'il arrivait à peine à
monter arrivera toujours plein de gens
et maintenant tu publics et pas chez
lieux communs c'est quoi les quais pas
les quais bas sont des petits paquets en
verlan tepa paquet sont des petites
feuilles de papier qui est en moi j'ai
envie qu'ils étaient en vente lyon se
trouve à la auquel on met la dope
en l'occurrence l'héroïne jusqu'à 36 ans
c'est pas toucher à la daube du tout et
puis tu as une histoire d'amour
malheureuse avec un homme s'appelle
jérôme oui des préférences pour être pas
c'est que les hommes
oui
total et s'est pas laissée sans rien
sans rien en échange
sans aucune raison oui c'était en soit
l'annoncé fin et ce midi c'est un bon
produit
ces avis exprimés en sortir en écrivant
qui saperait si t'as pas été vraiment
hâte en sortir de raconter tout ça ne va
pas l'aider dans ce que j'ai replongé au
milieu de bouquins donc oui j'ai les
crocs cours j'aurais dû écrire ça
j'aurais dû laisser passer quelques
années soit jamais franchir couteau
s'est décroché deux fois déjà
j'ai décroché à la pointe du cac et tu
dis c'est très difficile de décrocher
parce que c'est comme une cicatrice
panda dans le sens que tu penses que ça
modifie la physiologie du corps qui nous
a créé un besoin que les tirs et précis
oui je crois et je faisais allusion à la
syphilis mais l'image je crois que ça
s'est inscrit dans sa phase qui
cicatrise vont n'oublie jamais la noble
décroché n'a d'après dit que même les
gens qui décroche après nous entoure
divin espèce de monde psychologique -
gerber oui il suffit d'être en face d'un
macho
enfin la douleur qu'on craque et
irréversible la drogue enfants vont très
bien longtemps bouquin finit par partout
résumé c'est à dire qu'il ya plus de
sexe genre parce qu'il ya plus de boue
il ya plus de relations avec les gens
parce qu'ils peuvent vous aider on
trouvait aussi en panne avec vous et
finalement tout se réduit à ce ticket
pas moi toute ma vie est là dedans
oui il faut de l'aventuré terrifiante un
moteur tu prends aucun aucune précaution
c'est dire toute la vérité at il ajouté
avec des shooteuses qui avait déjà servi
oui je prends en aux anges et chauffée
derrière les recrues ça c'est inévitable
quand on n'est pas aussi qu duron le
sida on s'en fout je ne pense pas parce
que
imagine que tu trouves atta
car dieu est chaud j'en achetais la pâte
pompe suscitait en banque
tu vas prendre la vendée qui ont la
forme de la prospective ça c'est un truc
je crois je prends un tableau je pense
que tous les séropositifs
non j'ai fait a dit despatie
ça vire à un miracle de tous les noms
mais pas mais c'est vrai que quand on
line vous qu'à une espèce de mort
souhaité c'est à dire qu'on a
l'impression que finalement ils sont
tous en train d'attendre
l'overdose ouais tu vas aller délivrer
tout ça en quelque sorte
non oui tout à fait logiquement perdre
un jour ils parlent ils vont s'en mettre
un peu trop dans la pour la pompe
l'étude y est
et puis qu'ils vont être délivrés
secondes quand mes amitiés d'une
violence de riverains du mas nous et je
la crois que la seule solution c'est
l'amour en tout cas quand tu n'as pas
sûr faut consentir ou confie quand tu te
dis qu'il ne put en sentira jamais je
compte sur la constitution il vaut mieux
ça que nous devenir junkie et tallinn
est plus qu une penny stock important
sharklo champions de l'est tous
champions ouais quand on shoote beaucoup
tu dis là la vie m'emmerde j'aime pas
j'aime pas les petits oiseaux où on ne
gêne pas les fleurs c'est toujours le
calme
ouah ça va toujours emmerdé diplomatico
tu regrettes des années au monde
oui on peut être un bon alors ce qui est
très récent dans son bouquin c'est style
tu dis il ya un style qui trick
journalistique très réaliste très anti
lyrique justement compte tenu de ce que
tu viens me dit on peut le comprendre
tu dis je resserre les boulons ça me
fait penser à une phrase de marguerite
durak h 30 ou 10 et j'écrirai trend
aimons ça s'est resserré les boulons en
face à celle verlan en sa senteur
proches comme c'est vrai que les seules
critiques
j'vous négatif qu'a eu sur le bouquin
toi tu dis
vu que toute façon dans ce milieu là
tout est à l'envers du reste du monde
moi j'utilise les mots à l'envers c'est
vrai que la démarche et est juste mais
c'est vrai que c'est un peu anachronique
tous vers lens m'a dit que ça faisait un
peu que je te breton marshall ans qui
serait la mère josselin qui est tout
sauf assurée c'est l'amer josse énergie
au sein du nouvel an alors on pourra le
par le conseil osi sur une question
aussi vote
non ce que je voudrais c'est que les
toxiques ou parle comme ça si tu ne
comprends pas ça tu ne peut pas naviguer
dans le monde et toxico pas possible
c'est déjà lu un livre de jean-françois
je serai jamais meia lua ligue de toi tu
n'as fait l'effort
j'ai de faire un petit truc la lentille
portrait chinois l'ancien portrait
chinois d'habitude on dit aux gens si
vous étiez une fleur je serai une
orchidée de faire ça tout bien vu que ça
t'emmerde en couleurs c'est étaient une
injure
je crois que fumer vous était une
maladie
cancer de la gorge toute règle
le prix des glaces a parlé bien partir
et si tu étais un vie ce sujet tous les
vices alors
on choisit des jeux cette élection est
une arme sera un point à quoi le fleuve
s'est jamais tué quelqu'un jusqu'à
maintenant tu le ferais pourquoi pas si
tu replonge été un jour je sais pas il
ya un mec je vous dans bank
j'aurais pu le faire quand j'étais était
vraiment accrocheur et je connais
quelqu'un puisse faire pour pas grand
chose pour bagage un poison varsovie
ceara landre leur sérieux si mallory
propose des recettes soit avec vous ça
l'odeur
ray de l'hérault mais c'est pas de refus
d'un supplice le pal
et si tva l'accident champions prévient
dans un crash en avion je veux près
ces explosions leers voilà un flash on
over et maintenant